this is not going to end well when it
ends and the bigger question is when
does it end are those redditors heroes
are they villains
they're just people it's uh it's it's
nothing short of remarkable
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
the world is indeed a strange place
these days it seems like anything can
happen
in early 2021 a viral battle erupted in
the most unlikely of places
the stock market it was publicized as a
conflict between investors on the
internet
and large hedge funds but what's the
full story
and what consequences will we see
it all started in september of 2019 when
an armchair investor by the name of
keith gill noted something
interesting in the stock market he sat
down at his computer
signed into youtube and started talking
about what he saw
keith also took to reddit and would
start posting about his observations
most of the people in the forum laughed
at him but keith believed that the
payoff would be huge
nobody at the time understood what he
was doing but his decision would set in
motion
one of the most insane moments in
financial history
it would bring multi-billion dollar
hedge funds to their knees and spark a
social uprising between the public and
wall street
sit back and relax as we uncover the
story of how one reddit user kicked off
a revolution
that rocked the financial world
you are watching cold fusion tv
in the year 2000 bill clinton signed the
commodity futures modernisation act and
ushered in the age of financialization
without much hesitation the financial
sector began to have an increasing
influence over the overall economy
instead of producing goods or services
large sectors of the economy
became dedicated to engineering creative
ways to make money with money
bill clinton later admitted that he'd
made a huge mistake
but it was far too late the floodgates
for market speculation
were opened ever more exotic financial
products were invented and sold
the banks and financial players were
supposed to regulate themselves
but this didn't happen financial
products would be traded privately
without supervision
there was no connection to any real
world underlying asset
however the risks they created in the
financial system
were real the speculation finally got
out of control in 2008
causing a crisis in the global financial
system there were millions of bailouts
for the banks and hedge funds while
millions of ordinary people
lost their jobs work became scarce
and many struggled to provide for their
families
as the dust settled the anger grew and
in 2011 it erupted into a movement
called
occupy wall street its purpose was to
protest against the bankers
and show that they couldn't get away
with gambling with other people's money
but something strange happened within a
year it seemed that everyone lost focus
on the financial issue
and instead of challenging the banks and
holding them to account society began to
fight one another over their personal
differences
meanwhile the financial institutions
could breathe a sigh of relief at the
turn of events
fast forward to 2020 and a global
pandemic would trigger lockdowns around
the world
in the united states about 47 of jobs
come from small businesses
so naturally shutting down the economy
spelled economic devastation
with people out of work and many growing
restless with their situation
they began to notice something while
their businesses were shut down
and their jobs gone it seemed that
amazon walmart
and other massive corporations were just
fine in fact
they were thriving not only this but the
financial markets began to boom
the rich were once again getting richer
while they
lost everything wealth was being
extracted from the little guy
to the financialized economy with jobs
gone
nothing to do and only limited
government support in the form of
stimulus checks
the stage was set for a revolution
against the financial institutions
in 2012 30 year old jamie rogozinski
would browse a forum called reddit from
time to time
he had made some extra cash at the time
while working in washington dc
so jaime had the idea to gather a
community around investing
he would start a subreddit called wall
street bets in order to do this
for the first few years the wall street
bets forum only managed a few thousand
users
then in 2019 some brokerage giants
eliminated trading
commissions for their apps they made
trading free
and accessible in a moment retail
investing exploded onto the scene
the number of wall street bet
subscribers quickly grew past 500
000 then one million during the crash of
march 2020
by this time the community had taken on
a mind of its own
jaime the original forum's creator
voiced his concerns that it was
spiraling out of control and deleted
some moderators as he saw fit
he was met with backlash and was ejected
by other moderators
this was now bigger than jaime in a
statement to the wall street journal
he noted that wall street bets is no
longer what it used to be
while all this was going on a user in
the wall street bets forum
by the name of keith gill was keenly
studying something he'd noticed
on his youtube channel the armchair
investor keith gill
laid out his game plan it was to buy
some stock of a company called gamestop
an unassuming store founded in 1984
and familiar to most people in the
united states
gamestop had a simple business model to
sell video games and gaming equipment
out of its physical store locations
naturally this model became less
lucrative as more gamers moved to online
purchases
it seemed that gamestop was on the ropes
of facing bankruptcy
so why did keith want to buy such a
company
well he thought that this view was
overblown although the company was
closing stores
by looking at their 10k quarterly
financial reports they actually had a
lot of cash
and could pay off their debt and the
company could recover just with some
good management
on his youtube channel keith would prove
his points with evidence
he was reading blogs press releases
seeking alpha articles
company notes and more all to make his
case that the stock was actually
undervalued
for example he knew that new gaming
consoles were coming out soon
and this would be great for gamestop
sales he also theorized that the move to
digital was actually a lot slower than
people were thinking
and this would be important for the
company over the next couple of years
he pulled up articles and videos of
people talking about physical game discs
versus digital downloads
he realized that there was still a lot
of demand for physical games
which meant even more revenue for
gamestop he was diligent
and left no stone unturned to make his
case
he invested 53 000 in gamestop in
september
this was 2018 2019 it's 2020 right now
and the trend is clearly
going toward digital but this is my
point is that you're still seeing some
countries that are still heavily
skewed too physical and i don't think
one year later
all of a sudden everyone's going to be
buying digital i just need to make sure
that gamestop isn't going bankrupt
in that people are still buying discs
and that there are still demands for
gamestop for just a couple of years
because if that's the case
gamestop is likely undervalued a small
number of redditors also agreed with
keith
but then they noticed something even
more peculiar 84
of gamestop stock was held as short
positions
that is betting that the price would
fall this was highly unusual
it turned out that hedge funds had
colluded in selling short the stock
publicly stating that the price would go
down therefore
making the millions they sold over 130
percent of the gamestop stock
short at this moment
the redditors had a unique opportunity
in financial history
a populist financial movement could be
hatched if played right
but first to fully understand the game
plan we need to first describe what
short selling is
say you borrow some vintage baseball
cards from a friend for about 400
but promise to give the cards back to
him next week after he agrees to give
you the baseball cards you sell those
same cards to a dealer for 400
because that's the market price of the
cards
you do this because you expect the price
to drop
[Music]
say in one week's time the market price
of the baseball cards drops to 300
you buy the baseball cards back from the
dealer at the new price of 300.
since you originally sold it to the
dealer for 400 you now have a hundred
dollars left over
after this you return the cards to your
friend that's basically short selling
except you have to pay interest to your
friend for borrowing the cards
now here's the clincher if after a week
the market price of the cards was to
rise to five hundred dollars
then you'd be out of pocket one hundred
dollars by the time you give the cards
back to your friend
but the thing is if the price of the
cards keeps rising
and say that there's lots of people that
are in the same position as yourself
they'll all want to buy their cars back
from their dealers and sell them back to
their friends to limit their losses
but the action of a mass buying of cards
actually raises the market price of the
cards
this is called a short squeeze that last
scenario is what happened to these hedge
funds
in essence with short selling the losses
are almost limitless
i think the hedge funds are the dumb
money
right every experienced hedge fund
manager knows
you do not short a stock with 138
um short interest in terms of risk and
reward which is what
investing is the retail guy nailed this
so the hedge funds overstayed their
welcome in these shorts
so back to gamestop the fatal mistake
the hedge funds made
is that they were greedy they could have
rode the gamestop stock
down from fifty dollars and bought it
back at five dollars but they hung in
there without selling
seemingly because they wanted every last
cent from their bet
it seems like they were just waiting for
gamestop to go bankrupt
unfortunately for the hedge funds this
left themselves exposed and wide open
for an attack
their expectation was it would be driven
to zero and they would never have to
buy the shares back they got greedy even
though it was down to four or three
two dollars i think 250 or something at
one point they just kept
holding their position as opposed to
buying it back
closing out the position and and not
risking the extra couple bucks
uh per share and it backfired
[Music]
while keith was posting about his
findings another reddit forum user
posted a seven-point document titled
quote
bankrupting institutional investors for
dummies featuring gamestop
the user pointed out that hedge funds
were fatally exposed
the wall street bets forum loved the
idea it was brilliant
the risk to the redditors was limited
the worst that could happen is that the
stock goes to zero and they lose all
their money
on the other hand the risk to the hedge
funds was immense
the hedge funds could lose more money
than they put in and worse still
they had borrowed money to short sell
the plan was for the reddit army to keep
buying gamestop stock driving up the
price
and making the hedge funds lose more and
more money the hedge funds would be
forced to abandon their positions
and cover their losses by buying shares
from the market to return to their
lenders
and like our baseball card example
earlier this very act drives up the
prices even more
it was a cascading event leading to a
dramatic rise in the stock price in a
very short time period
it was almost like a bug in a video game
being exploited
as the stock kept rising and the hedge
funds kept losing money
reddit realized that they could bring
the hedge fund to their knees
it was a digital form of protest the
masses were playing the banks and hedge
funds own game
against them by january 26th
gamestop was the single most traded
stock in the u.s stock market with
volumes matching that of the five
biggest tech giants combined
gamestop saw its share price spike from
just a few dollars in 2020
to a peak of over 490 transforming a
firm that was valued at less than 200
million in april 2020
into a company worth more than 28
billion
buzz began to build around the story and
the news media ran with the narrative of
the people
taking back control by playing the game
of the bankers against them but as
you'll soon see
there may be more to the story the
reddit rebellion continuing to play out
today games stop
surging again after hours it's amazing
that
the average person can now
actually get a fair shake since against
the hedge funds
at this point like i said i don't care
about what my financial return is
now it's about sticking it to the man
wall street speculation and these
hedge fund guys they've been
manipulating the stock market
in a very similar way forever by the
28th of january the hedge funds and
short sellers had lost 70 billion
dollars
and 5 000 u.s firms had been affected it
was
all out war
[Music]
as news of the game stop rebellion
spread around the world billboards began
to appear
telling the public what to do buy
gamestop stock
the first billboard was in new york but
soon more billboards appeared in san
diego
salt lake city dallas orlando and more
on the 28th of january a small physical
protest occurred on wall street
itself meanwhile online
redditors encouraged each other to hold
strong and not to sell
no matter what a term that they called
diamond hands
the plan was the longer the redditors
held out the more damage they would do
to the hedge funds
this would be in the order of millions
and possibly billions of dollars
due to the large amounts of interest
they had to pay
the news soon reached the white house i
was concerned about the stock market
activity we're seeing around games stop
um and have there been any conversations
with the sec about
uh how to proceed well um i'm also
happy to repeat that we have the first
female treasury secretary and a team
that's surrounding her and often
questions about market we'll send to
them
secretary yellen and others are
monitoring the situation it's a good
reminder though that the stock market
isn't the only measure of the health of
our econo
our economy while this was happening
the big sharks sensed an opportunity
larger trading professionals joined the
fight
but only for their own profit blackrock
and eight other wall street titans made
a combined
16 billion on game stock in a matter of
days
you see it wasn't just the redditors
that made money
and that's a key point in the story wall
street always finds a way to win
there's definitely been larger players
participating
and being quiet about it you know
there's no reason they wouldn't
necessarily join in
it benefits them they make a good trade
and they also happen to
knock out one of their rivals
other editors noticed that more
companies in bad shape were also being
heavily shorted
this included nokia amc movie theaters
and more
other coordinated attacks were made to
bid up these prices too
and it seemed to be working melvin
capital a heavy short seller was a large
casualty
they had to be bailed out to the tune of
2.7 billion dollars by citadel
another hedge fund this was according to
bloomberg
meanwhile three of gamestop's biggest
investors gained over two
billion dollars in personal wealth from
the frenzy other small traders were now
able to pay back student loans
another subreddit called wall street
bets gives back donated their earnings
to charities and organizations
as for our armchair investor keith gill
who had only invested around 53 000
back in 2019 his bet on gamestop had now
turned into a fortune of 48 million
dollars at the height of the stock rally
but it wouldn't be smooth sailing for
him and many others
battle lines soon began to be drawn
discord stepped in
and banned communication between the
redditors on their platform citing hate
speech
but it only fueled the fire the wall
street bets forum on reddit would grow
from 5 million subscribers
to 8 million in a couple of days
facebook was next to step in
and banned the robin hood trading group
with over 157
000 members the popular trading app
robinhood made its number one in the app
store before banning retailers from
buying gamestop stock
nokia amc and other stocks are also
included in the ban
only selling was allowed the actions by
robin hood
enraged the general public who was by
now fully aware of the situation
multiple class action lawsuits were
launched and politicians and celebrities
alike got involved
blocking people from buying stocks and
only letting them sell would be pushing
the price down artificially
this could have been perceived as a form
of market manipulation
the perception was that robin hood was
siding with the large hedge funds as
they do receive funding from citadel and
others
in return the hedge funds get massive
amounts of data from the small investors
and from that they can figure out how to
make money
in fact robin hood has made 700 million
dollars in selling user data to hedge
funds
during all of this an sec investigation
was also triggered
in his company's defense according to
ceo vlad tanev
because of the unprecedented market
conditions robin hood was forced to
raise 1 billion dollars to keep things
running
elon musk would make headlines when he
grilled vlad in an interview
and so thursday morning right
so i'm sleeping but at
3 30 a.m pacific um our
operations team receives a file from
the nscc which is the national
securities clearing corporations
they give us a file with a deposit and
the
the request was around three billion
dollars
seems weird that you'd get a sudden 10
billion dollar demand you know
three three billion okay three billion
around you know
just suddenly out of nowhere um and um
but we had no choice in this case we had
to conform to
our regulatory capital requirements who
controls this
this organization this clearinghouse
basically what people are wondering is
like
did you sell your clients down the river
or do you have no choice if you had no
choice that's understandable but then
you know we got to find out why you had
no choice and who are these people that
are saying you have no choice
this all raises questions if this chaos
hit robin hood from just a few stocks
what would happen if there was
widespread volatility across the whole
market
as february rolled around the sentiment
changed
the game stock price began to drop and
fear spread throughout the reddit
message boards
some users had lost hundreds of
thousands and some
millions keith gill had now lost over 14
million
but they all held their position they
believed that the hedge funds would have
to buy back their positions to cover
their shorts
sooner or later and this would cause the
price to rise once again
though it is possible that although the
redditors held the big sharks
had already sold i can commend the
redditors for their strong conviction in
doing what they believe was right
but many have broken the number one rule
of investing only invest what you're
willing to lose
though maybe some view it as a donation
to a good cause
rather than an investment as the stock
price began to wane
a new new cycle began to emerge the
redditors had moved from gamestop onto
silver
many physical silver dealers saw a
massive increase in demand and the
silver price
shot up but this outcome was not
possible by reddit alone
the silver market is too large and even
the redditors knew this
there were many posts on the forum
saying stay away from silver is just a
distraction from gamestop
the consensus on the forum was that the
news media was lying
and they were the ones causing the rush
to silver this broke the trust and media
for many that understood what was going
on
by this stage the wall street bets
forums were on fire
there are reports of large institutions
failing to deliver borrowed game stop
stock
and hedge funds using a technique called
a short ladder attack
this is where hedge funds sell hundred
share increments back and forth to each
other in order to drop
the price the rumor mills were swirling
and it became almost impossible to truly
determine what was happening
there will no doubt be more calls for
regulation
in a cnbc interview nasdaq ceo adena
friedman
called for the monitoring of social
media chatter to stamp out coordinated
stock moves
i think that in general when we evaluate
how we would
manage through a situation where you see
a significant run-up
in a stock that's not based on news
that's not based on fundamentals
what we do is we do have technology that
evaluates
um social media chatter and if we see a
significant rise in the chatter on
social media channels
and then we also match that up against
unusual trading activity
we will potentially halt that stock
robin hood would slowly open up the
buying of the targeted stocks
but not before vlad was ordered to
testify in front of congress
janet yellen formerly chairwoman of the
federal reserve
and current treasury secretary is going
to call a regulatory meeting over the
gamestop rebellion
yellen has formally received over 700
in speaking fees from citadel making it
a conflict of interest
she is currently seeking a waiver to
conduct the hearing
[Music]
the gamestop rebellion has set a
precedent this is the very first
instance of the intersection between
social media and the financial system
the idea has since gone global bloomberg
has reported the targeting of shorted
stocks from amsterdam to sydney
in europe some of the most shorted
stocks jumped 20
or more and in tokyo short sold stocks
jumped by about seven percent or more on
another note
there could be implications for the
wider market in the future if another
short squeeze was organized
and a big firm was to blow up it could
end up being deemed too big to fail by
the government and once again
another taxpayer-funded bailout could
occur this isn't to mention systemic
risks
the financial system is completely
entangled complex
and fragile as hedge funds need capital
to cover their shorts
this could cause some selling elsewhere
our trust in the financial system is at
an all-time low
over 23 percent of all us dollars in
existence were printed last year
meanwhile 40 of americans don't have 400
in the bank for emergency expenses this
is from the country that is the world's
reserve currency
so it has global implications this story
has revealed how volatile
and detached from reality stocks can be
these days low interest rates
stimulus excessive financialization and
quantitative easing
has transformed the global economy from
productive innovative
and earnings focused to a decaying husk
of speculation
and financial engineering for years
companies were buying back their own
stock so the price would go up and look
good on paper
when the cost of borrowing money is
cheap no one cares about risk
the gamestop rebellion was a wake-up
call average people
aren't happy with this they're saying
you can't keep doing this to us
there's a great quote by warren buffett
price is what you pay
but value is what you get
the wall street bets crowd destroyed
that relationship but the twist is
it could be argued that the relationship
between price and value
has been destroyed and manipulated all
the way back since the clinton days
when he ushered in the age of
financialization
january of 2021 marked a cultural shift
in the way that the financial market is
viewed
for the reddit users that were fed up
and just wanted change to happen
their objective may have already been
achieved people
are once again talking about the
unfairness of the financial system
but will the new regulations that stem
from this shut down the little guy
that remains to be seen but regardless
one day
this story will be taught in business
schools around the world
no matter the outcome
and that my friends is the story of how
one guy on reddit
started a financial revolution a story
that's still unfolding
[Music]
thanks for watching if you did enjoy
this episode and want to own a memory
from this crazy moment in financial
history
i've got some merch to do just that it's
a gamestonk logo
in the middle of the cold fusion logo
with the text infinite money glitch
written on it
it's a fun take on the situation and a
reminder to have a laugh sometimes
links will be below if you want to grab
one i'm looking to make better content
and more content for you guys so this
merch helps out with that
special thanks to john gross a redditor
who's been following the story and was
willing to talk about the situation as
he's seen it on the message boards
if you want to see anything on science
technology business or history
consider subscribing to cold fusion i
release videos every week
alright so i'll catch you next week for
the next episode which will be part two
of the intel story
for real this time alright my name is
tagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion
cheers guys
have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking
you